I'm going to introduce Robin to the new
Les Moonves puppet with his penis
sticking out and he's got Hollywood
white teeth Chiclets Robin yes les
darling I want to show you something let
me get a glass of wine I'll be right
back okay hold on I'm back Robin oh my
goodness I'm completely nude with my
penis out where your pants yeah how do
you like my [ __ ] all right I'll cover my
[ __ ]
look les you're very excited I can see
that I was so shocked when Ralph walked
in and he made a Julie Chen puppet
Robin Robin hi Julie look at you this is
my sleepy look wait hold on okay there
you are I can see you now oops
bless his pants just disappeared so I
got to get back to the bedroom
excuse me Robin who are you I'm a female
duck I'm a female doctor let's see your
lab coat I have a lab coat on I am the
woman I'm the nurse no the doctor that
me are confusingly shut up Fred I am the
doctor who spoke to Ronan Farrow who
brought down and I'm talking in quotes
now because I'm a doctor and I
accrediting air quotes that's right I
was with less and I want to show you
what happened less if you would come in
please you're willing to reenact I am
going to reenact what happened with less
give me one second I'll be right back
all right doctor hold on Robin less will
be coming in shortly I'm no Jim Henson
it takes me a minute you're not ready oh
hi
oh my god oh my robe this is exactly
what I saw you walked in she walked in
and I was nude already for my exam oh
boy
didn't you see my [ __ ] yes I see it so I
was like oh hey doctor would you give me
a [ __ ] I said no with that less
starts jerking off in front of me like
right there that's so have you ever had
that happen before a doctor never in my
entire career because most people want
to treat me nicely so I don't kill them
in the examination yes why don't you
blow me you mean like this less you know
what you said when they told you what
the doctor said about that visit what
what did I say
you said all I did was kiss her and then
he calls me up with the phone hello
Doctor
this is les Moonves yeah I just want to
say I have a horrible problem I want to
apologize for yesterday because I jerked
off in front of you in the doctor's
office and I want to apologize because I
have a problem oh really what's your
problem my problem is I can't be alone
in a room and a woman and I'm sorry I
broke your Hippocratic oath yeah I took
an oath do not harm and do not suck dick
in the [ __ ] room okay [ __ ] you're
not that good-looking you know Brad Pitt
all right I got you all right I'm sorry
okay I just needed to get the poison out
and why don't you shove that stethoscope
up my ass you're disgusting no I never
put my pants on Robin with your pants
off all the time hey Robin you used to
be a nurse didn't you yes would you mind
coming over here and taking my cock's
blood pressure just wrap your hand
around this I would love to put a cuff
on that penis and blow it up mmm no it
sounds like you'd like that to most
women loved my [ __ ] you just heard from
maybe two or three who didn't know it
was 12 now no no I'm a lot of them alone
there's like three that really hated my
[ __ ] okay okay maybe two all right
even the
they've now spoken out you think what
they'd love sure yeah I know they loved
it I know there was the one girl who
vomited in her office she didn't like my
[ __ ] maybe that I okay no one else has
ever vomited after I shove my [ __ ] in
their mouth they loved it which is
verification that they loved it yeah
remind the story of me in the car and I
just forced the woman's head down with
my [ __ ] she really loved that I'm not
kidding I was there I should know what
about the woman who jumped out of the
car and ran hey Oh her yeah yeah she
didn't like my car but everyone else did
and whatever this Ronan Farrow character
is uh-huh how about interviewing the
women who vomited out of joy when they
blew me if I could speak this Ronan
Farrow is very unfair how so
because he did an interview any of the
women who loved my car where is that
they haven't come for would you mind
looking me in your eyes and not at my
penis I'm feeling a little weird